Harry Potter TV series and development
my only question is why didn't they do
it years ago
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
as you know if you're a regular side
tracker we've been talking a lot about
or everything going on at Warner
Brothers this merger between Warner
Brothers and Discovery into Warner
Brothers Discovery Inc David saslav as
the new CEO and how he's been mixing
things up at Warner Brothers they have
scrapped loads of projects and they are
announcing and working on loads of
others we're going to be getting a June
The Sisterhood TV series we're going to
be getting a reboot of True Blood which
is actually a series I adored and I
think that would be great we're going to
be getting more Game of Thrones TV
series like the Jon Snow project
but now according to Sarah Aubry head of
original content at hbr Max we're also
going to be getting a Harry Potter TV
series now I'm going to be able to tell
you about a little bit of an exclusive
I've been speaking to somebody that
works in and around Warner Brothers now
and they know what the project is going
to be based on
welcome to Hogwarts
but we'll come back to that in a second
if you haven't subscribed already please
do and like and share the video wherever
the hell you want also if you enjoy the
content and you want to support the
Channel please hit the join button also
we have our sister Channel Sidetrack
size where we do lots of little best
bits from the lives and lots of other
fun silly little videos so please go and
subscribe to sites
now I should say that this information
was actually passed to me about a week
ago but this is the first chance I've
got to talk about it but it has actually
been confirmed by Sarah Aubry in an
interview she was talking to variety
about how she has actually kept her job
when others around her have lost theirs
how everything is going in a completely
different direction at Warner Brothers
and HBO Max now which she has her margin
orders she has her project plan over the
next few years and she knows the
directions she's steering the ship now
she seems to be really excited and
optimistic about the future even though
she does talk about a restricted budget
a healthy budget still for HBO Max HBO
Max being one of the more wealthy of the
streaming services currently but
restricted as we all know we're going
through a bit of a living crisis at the
moment
in the UK it's just really nice we're
going into a recession people are
holding on to their wallets they're
starting to try to save money rather
than spend it and one of the things that
we can easily save money on is what we
watch for the TV we can get rid of a few
streaming services and people have been
so why now for Harry Potter
fair to say the Fantastic Beasts Series
has been a slight disappointment I
actually genuinely believe if Johnny
Depp had been in the last move it would
have been the best one of all of them
but unfortunately because of his legal
issues he wasn't invited back and I
think the film suffered for it
but it is fair to say the Fantastic
Beasts Series has not anything like
reached the heights of the Harry Potter
series
so the time does feel right for Harry
Potter to return but to return to the
smaller screen
so what have I been told this project
will be based around well it is very
early development these are just
conversations at the moment but what I'm
being told is that the project will be
based around JK Rowling's short stories
of Hogwarts
of heroism hardship and dangerous
Hobbies now this means at least in part
the series will be based around a
younger McGonagall Lupine
um cattle burn and treilorni
foreign
to use that spell
and we'll get to see a lot more of the
inner workings of Hogwarts a lot more
details about the professors a lot of
detail that will give us a really
interesting backstory to a lot of what
happened in the Harry Potter series
I'm also being told that in very early
conversations there has been talk about
could they do a young Voldemort
Voldemort was after your time
Voldemort is my past
present
and future is there a way we could see a
young Tom Riddle at Hogwarts well
apparently the conversations are
happening they're not quite sure how to
do it with a bit of class but let's see
what they come up with so guys get in
the comments tell me what you think is a
Harry Potter series something you'd
enjoy personally I'm a massive Harry
Potter fan it's probably the only books
I've actually read from beginning to end
I shouldn't really admit that but I love
the movies as well I've not enjoyed
Fantastic Beasts as much I think that's
fair to say
actually fell asleep through one in the
cinema I don't even know how you do that
but I did a TV series though that gets
back to Hogwarts and gets back to the
roots of what I love about Harry Potter
oh yeah that'd be great but get in the
comments and tell me what you think
also if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
if you enjoy the content and you want to
support the channel consider hitting the
join Button as always guys please stay
safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]